richard l'émission est terminée
il est l'heure de quelques questions un
petit peu plus personnel c'est son nom
personnel je peux te renvoyer non mais
combien la grille je risque pas grand
chose comme dix mois bohringer weir dix
ans tu crois pas que tu es le roi des
démagos aaa que ça me plaît ça et ça ne
plaît le roi des démagos non je ne suis
pas à l'union je suis pas démago non je
sais que ça se dit mais je n'arrive pas
à savoir vraiment si ce mot et est
péjoratif aussi on l'a rendue psg
voulait dire mon cher à bissau que
j'aurai une une tendance à avoir l'amour
du genre humain je dis rien j'écoute
votre jambe
oui c'est l'amour du jeu à partir de ce
moment là si et je crie trop fort si on
appelle ça être le roi des démagos bat
tant pis pour les autres ils n'ont pas
entendu les vêtements mon coeur est ce
que c'est parce que tu es capricorne
comme jésus-christ que tu passes ton
temps à vouloir refaire le monde
on savait que c'était une chose là le
jour où il m'a été révélé que
jésus-christ était du trône et des camps
du capricorne jeu j'ai cru que c'était
une blague privé d'eton capricorne et
j'ai appris que michel-ange aussi été
pris corps
c'est pour ça que tu me passes ton temps
à refaire le monde c'est peut-être parce
que parce que je les aime tellement ce
monde que j'aimerais bien qu'il soit un
monde une fois pour toutes
alors chacun y va avec sa petite ruelle
moi je jette un grand mondial voilà
merci c'est pas de risque pour moi ça et
chats alors richard dans la série
confessions d'un barjots suite
es-tu favorable au divorce
je m'interdis de penser je me j'aime
l'idée qu'un couple aille loin au sens
je me sens à l'avortement
ouais lorsque j'entends toujours des
gens dire commun à l'avortement mais
c'est ok je comprends l'idée de vie
médecin
il ya des gens qui se retrouvent dans
des situations absolument infernal quoi
odieux même du de l'aoa toute sa
miséricorde
faudrait peut-être lui demander à lui
plutôt que de demander à ses serviteurs
à la peine de mort non même pour les
assassins d'enfants
bah oui je suis obligé continue à la
légalisation des drogues douces
ouais ça c'est un vaste débat j'ai connu
certaines l'égalisation à londres dans
les années 60
amsterdam en hollande on connaît aussi
[Musique]
je sais pas c'est quand même tient un
couteau des lycées de petites écoles
comme un maximum d'emplois et iroquois
et que j'ai pas envie que mes gosses
tomber là-dedans feront ce qu'ils
voudront quand ils seront au moment où
on veut dire oui ou non pourrait on
penser une chose tuer pour aux contres
en fait je sais pas
quels sont tes tabou tabou tabou tabou
ce qui me choque
à vrai dire un truc moi même je me
choque c'est choquant quand je suis
chaud quand des choquant quand je suis
un des sens orgueilleux vanille que tu
as honte de toiles en ces moments là
ouais moins en moins comme ça moi je
trouve
ouais mais y'a encore du boulot à faire
déjà fait pas mal
ouais c'est bon est-ce que tu prends
deux ans je crois en l'esprit
tu crois aux choses qui vibre lui croire
à la serrure divine oui je crois au
diable bah oui je crois aussi à l'autre
je crois je crois la mauvaise
enfin il doit y avoir un diable
sympathique et bien diable parfaitement
tordu c'est sûr donc je crois au diable
sympathique mais je crois aussi où
diable complète autant du y'a qu'à voir
les événements
il faut bien qu'ils gardent qui soit
dans cette affaire la postière donc le
diabolique jacques c'est la première
fois que vous entrez dans un
confessionnal
oui quel effet ça vous fait ce je vous
dirais que j'aime beaucoup l'atmosphère
des églises d'adversaires du sacré et
donc ça me fait le même effet vous êtes
déjà allongé sur le divan d'un psy qu'un
d'un psychiatre même pour rigoler pour
rigoler mais avec des gens qui n'étaient
pas si ma mère n'avait pas besoin de
porter l'étoile jaune
elle était jaune de la tête aux pieds
c'est cette sensibilité de colonisés qui
a guidé votre vie je crois oui c'est
pour ça que vous avez défendu barbie non
pas comme un tortionnaire nazi mais
comme
membres d'une armée d'occupation comme
l'armée française en algérie où l'armée
américaine au vietnam où l'armée russe
en afghanistan pour moi barbie est un
personnage tragique de notre temps ces
officiers subalternes d'une armée
d'occupation
dans un pays qui résiste vous avez dit
comme roger nimier tout humanise le
mythe étrangers expliquez vous je veux
dire ceci c'est que il y à une certaine
morale qui se cache derrière les mots
humaniste derrière les mots droits de
l'homme qui exprime le l'état de la
société en europe à l'heure actuelle
cette morale cette vision du monde qui
n'aimait pas général d'ailleurs est le
résultat du lycée est l'aboutissement
d'une histoire et je trouve que vouloir
imposer cette vision du monde à tous les
pays à toutes les nations c'est faire fi
de leurs cultures différentes de leur
histoire différente leur vision du monde
qui est différente
c'est manifestement n'avoir pas du
cinglé est ce que vous auriez défendu
adolf hitler
s'il était venu me voir et qu'il m'avait
dit je suis certainement l'homme dans
l'histoire du monde qui est l'objet des
accusations les plus graves
je crois que c'est incontestable mon
procès effet d'avancer est encore une
cause perdue mais parmi les millions
d'avocats qui dans le monde je pense que
vous êtes le seul capable de donner à
mes actes leur vraie signification leur
vraie dimension jeu ou non pas de
m'excuser je vous demande de
de décrire enfin de donner à ma vie sa
dîme sa véritable dimension à ce moment
là je crois que j'aurais accepté pendant
les six ans où vous avez disparu vous
étiez où quelque part vous dirai jamais
vous savez les liaisons qu'elle soit
amoureuse aux politiques qu'on cache
sont toujours les plus ça vous fait mal
d'être un écrivain raté d'abord écrivain
raté il aurait fait que je sois les
jeunes volonté d'être écrivain je serai
un livre c'est l agenda qui est sur ces
cellules
ça dépend et comme on le prendre mais le
ce que je voulais dire c'est le travail
d'avocat dans comme je le conçois est un
travail de création aussi avec son
originalité c'est quoi la beauté de
crime
la beauté du crime c'est cela ne veut
pas dire que tous les crimes sont beaux
la beauté du grip c'est que certains
crimes prennent une signification
universelle
est-ce que vous avez le sens du péché
non tu ne sais pas si tu es le fils d'un
arabe d'un juif ou d'un militaire
français
si tu pouvais choisir tu choisirais quoi
et
mais justement ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est justement je ne venais pas choisir
maintenant
if arabe catholique et
je peux aujourd'hui affirmé quand un
coutelier un tas de l'it et qu'on y
l'écho quand un juif est con il est con
et quand elle aura dès qu il est qu'on
imagine qu'un jour il y ait une nouvelle
guerre entre la france et l'algérie tu
serais de quel côté on se situerait du
côté de la raison est ce que tu te
souviens du jour où tu as le plus
détesté un français de france lui est
français
moi je dis toujours devant les copains
que je rencontre dans les potes et
tunisiens mais les français sont
racistes
je pense que la france n'est pas
essentiellement raciste j'espère que je
reprochais la formation de banaliser et
généralisée puis il faut pas généraliser
il faut se dire que la france elle est
la france des différents scellés
dans les différences d'opinion et les
avant les différences d'avis et on vit
et
la démocratie ça ça veut dire moins à le
pen il existe il est là
il doit vivre justement il doit il dont
il doit exister dans la mesure où on
fait partie du jeu démocratique
je crois que
la qualité de la france justement comme
la qualité de l'amérique c'est justement
d'avoir ce brassage de différents se
brasse ce brassage l'identité qui fait
vraiment la force la force d'un pays
le couscous c'est très très bon couscous
et vous vous n'hésitez pas à venir
manger dans les restaurants mange du
couscous parce que tout le monde dit
c'est bon couscous à la couscous et
arabes le couscous et szczesny imagine
qu'un jour tu ailles dans un petite
ville ou un village les gens savent pas
que le smile et que quelqu'un te traite
de sale arabe
je lui réponds quoi j'éclate de rire toi
qui a été choisi par une bonne soeur
soeur cécile au milieu de tous les
orphelins de saint vincent de paul à
constantine et qu'ils aient pu parce que
tu as été adopté par des parts des
kabyles vivant en france à voir la vie
que tu as est-ce que tu ne vois pas
derrière tu dis l'étoile mais pourquoi
ne pas y voir dieu directement pour peut
encore se cacher derrière ce nom parce
que tu crois pas pour finir que tu as
peur de croire en dieu
non puisque j'y crois c'est ce que tu
t'es déjà confessé à un beau coup quand
tu étais petit
quand j'étais à partir de ma profession
de foi j'ai été élevé par les soeurs
j'étais au l'institut de jeunes filles
saint-joseph j'ai appris les bonnes
manières
est-ce que tu approuve le divorce
[Musique]
oui oui je trouve ça plutôt bien de se
séparer si on s'entend pas est-ce que tu
approuve la contraception
oui est-ce que tu as trouve la sexualité
hors mariage
oui qu'est-ce que tu éprouves
l'homosexualité france qui va est-ce que
tu as prouve l'avortement
pas comme méthode de contraception le
bacon recours
détresse oui j'ai choqué les péchés
mortels alors les péchés mortels c'est
quoi déjà
j'ai su appliquer à oublier de cette
culpabilisation j'ai subi pendant mon
enfance
k comme si c est ce qu elle consistait à
envoyer au confessionnal à confesse qu
on l'adorait où je me souviens très bien
qu'on était dans l'est dans les couloirs
de
devant la chapelle et on se demandait ce
qu'on allait div
et c'est j'ai copié sur les péchés de
deux camarades de classe et je me
souviens que l'on m'avait demandé de
faire quelques je vous salue marie eykel
que votre père et ensuite je me suis dit
puisque j'ai payé pour ses péchés
je vais pouvoir en lego m haies
c'est je ne savais pas du tout où ni
l'esprit à faire ces choses là comme
deux volets 20 centimes dans la porte
monnaie de ma mère et c'est le concept
du péché qui m'a donné l'idée la
recherche de visages donc show salon wii
et cette tâche était plus tôt je les ai
connus à tu ne tueras point
ses dix commandements alors je sais plus
je confonds tout ce que tu touches par
orgueil
forcément on est obligé d'être d'être
orgueilleux un petit peu par envie celle
envie qui
ce qui nous pousse à à avoir la force
d'obtenir des choses donc c'est pas mal
tout ça à pêcher source à la bombe ont
moteur par lui
alors la luxure il ya et
il ya la morale
qui vient s'entrechoquer avec la
l'éducation faut pas oublier j'étais
très jeune en 68
donc moi j'ai vécu la libération
sexuelle la pilule donc la luxure
si tu es prête à tout si tu aimes la
personne avec qui tu es ça dépend si
cette personne ne mérite ou pas je suis
capable de me soigner de l'amour comme
si on me disait que j'avais la gangrène
je serai capable de mutiler d'un membre
je pense beaucoup de gens disent si
j'étais handicapé je préférais mourir je
j'ai déjà failli mourir je préférerais
être handicapé plutôt que de mourir et
je préfère vivre sans la personne que
j'aime serré négatif plutôt que que
négativement avec la personne que j'aime
je crois au bien et au mal mais pas dans
un sens forcément religieux type
j'ai peur de la religion puisqu'elle est
écrit par les hommes
donc elle est forcément écrites pour
mener
une masse pas très intelligente mais je
crois qu'on a besoin de croire en
quelque chose de plus grand que l'homme
puisque l'homme est très prétentieux et
je crois que ça peut s'appeler dieu et
que je crois que c'est bien rendu donc
tu crois que ça peut s'appeler comme ça
est ce que tu as déjà essayé d'embrasser
quelqu'un à travers une grille de
confessionnal non même toit ou tichy
personne ne vient est-ce que tu
regrettes des fois dans ta solitude ces
femmes et ces enfants abandonnés
bah je ne sais pas gelé je regrette tout
la vie est un long regret et une lente
espérance bien sûr toutes mes photos je
les connais et tous nos péchés je les
connais et d'une certaine manière je les
aime parce que je veux dire je me report
et le plaisir du repentir et quelque
chose d'accessible et c'est une
jouissance supplémentaires jeudi à l'ats
sellal la jouissance même de la
confession d'une apparente certaines
fois d'avoir des maîtresses qui ont
l'âge de ta fille elle chante plus
jeunes bon je veux dire pas du tout tu
penses des fois que ça pourrait tout à
fait oui
oui ou plutôt ma mère mais très violent
avec tout le talent que tu as
est-ce que des fois tu te dis pas porter
tout seul avec toi même tu es devenu un
très bon claude médiatique mais un clown
médiatique quand même je pense que notre
société veut ça veut dire que que dali
picasso passer pour des clowns et qui
peut faire de temps en temps une minute
de silence en garde sur le silence des
espaces infinis la différence de pascal
de bfre et philippe vous vous présentez
souvent comme un titi n'est à montmartre
en fête est née à coulommiers
vous avez honte de votre lieu de
naissance non mais comme je suis partie
de coulommiers alors vu six mois ça n'a
pas tellement influencée en revanche
j'ai passé toute mon enfance et toute
mon adolescence sur la butte montmartre
dont j'ai d'ailleurs comme vous pouvez
le constater gardé l'accent
vous avez une de vos origines sociales
non pas du tout d'ailleurs
elles sont modestes n'est digne il est
quoi votre papa mon papa est directeur
d'une petite société
ma maman était opticienne vous avez dit
je me suis longtemps haye
il s'est passé quoi depuis je me suis
réconcilié avec moi parce que je pouvais
pas faire autrement mais c'est vrai que
j'aurais voulu être autrement
physiquement autrement
intellectuellement
d'être plus pure plus dur et que à la
longue on fini par dresser le répertoire
de tous ses défauts et que dans le même
temps les qualités si elles existent
vous apparaissent moins on peut pas
prendre en grippe quelqu'un avec qui on
est condamné à vivre jusqu'à la fin et
de surcroît quelqu'un qui vous nourrit
aussi bien vous avez peur de grossir
j'ai eu peur de grossir j'ai vu que mon
accommoder bien on je voudrais pas
devenir énorme mais c'est pas mauvais
d'être enveloppé quand on fait un métier
public c'est inspire confiance à la
clientèle vous avez fait trente-cinq
mille interview à peu près et celle que
vous avez préféré c'est celle de lanza
del vasto parfois trois parce que
c'était un philosophe qui avait mis en
accord c'est rarissime c'est ses pensées
et ses actes c'est à dire qu'il prêchait
le dénuement et il vivait lui même dans
une communauté qu'il avait monté dans le
sud de la france et qui fonctionnait
comme aux premiers temps du monde
je veux dire sans aucune des ressources
du programme ils filaient lui-même le
lin dont il fabriquait ses vêtements
c'est une espèce d'adage d'or et puis
j'ai vu grâce à lui quelque chose que je
n'avais jamais observée jusque là dans
la société française ou contemporaines
l'image d'un désintéressement complet
vous deviez mourir demain vous
regretteriez dame a pas vécu le côté
lanza del vasto de la vie non je pense
qu'il n'était pas fait pour moi j'en ai
deux ports ging d'autre part bon j'ai eu
une bonne petite existence de deux
journalistes multimédia qui m'a permis
d'avoir droit à une existence à laquelle
ne me destinais
nîmes et et d'une lime et relation ni
mon physique sur un certain planche
quand même l'impression d'avoir tiré le
maximum du minimum de votre faveur
auprès du temps d'hier est une place
pour dieu y reste
en filigrane de tout ce que je fais le
regret de ne pas avoir eu la foi et leur
grève ou six grands de ne pas avoir
rencontré des gens susceptibles de me
communiquer la leur vous le regrettez
oui dis moi j'ai un ça a été dur à vivre
pendant tout ce temps d'être le beauf de
service un peu pour toutes ces raisons
j'ai joué des personnages qui était un
petit peu caricaturaux il est une tête
de français c'est vrai j'avais une tête
de français j'essaie de moustache là
je m'étais fait poussé par un service
peter zumthor contre espionnage était
pas passé inaperçu puis maintenant je
passais plus du tout une aperçu cette
fait souffrir de devoir en franche
meilleur à l'heure tous les soirs dans
les arènes de l'info canal + wii n'ont
pas souffert ces images c'est une
caricature d'une image qui était déjà
une caricature quand moi je le faisais
c'est le club est ni ce qu'est jane rien
vendu khouja liste dandy le pénis est
plus grave que ça s'est passé comment le
jour où tu a rasé sa moustache ouinsou
qu'il aurait préféré avoir le succès
l'argent que tu vas aujourd'hui ou être
le sosie de thierry lhermitte par
exemple c'est pas vrai parce que je
connais tous ses défauts thierry si tu
devais très incarnée tu peux faire est
réincarné en woody allen dont alain
delon sur ces portraits s'amuse à jouer
je ne profite des rôles rôles de jeunes
premiers sont assez chiant à jouer tu
crois que tu vas aller en enfer ou
paradis
je ne sais pas bien mais ce qui me
terrifie c'est que quand je vois les
gens qui sont perçus d'aller au paradis
ça me fout un peu les glandes tous ces
gens bien pensants bien honnête propre
ça ça va être terrible en fait les gens
que j'apprécie se retrouverait plus tôt
en enfer
et si tu devais mourir ton petit arthur
savez une seule chose à lui dire ça
serait quoi
pas trop de priestess étude favorable à
la peine de mort non je mets des queues
et qui est mort jeudi n'ont qu il faut
jamais tuer qui que ce soit ni une bête
ni encore moins un homme même pour les
assassins d'enfants même pour les
assassins d'enfants bien sûr il fallait
il faudra bien lui lui pardonner ya en
rien d'autre qui marchera mieux contre
la haine que l'amour tu crois en dieu
oui tu médites oui tu es plus tourné
vers les philosophies orientales que oui
plutôt mental plutôt oui l'hindouisme
tout ça oui ça ça me branche plus parce
que ces sondes et des religions qui te
quitte même pas des religions d'ailleurs
ma faim disons que c'était sur des
pratiques qui te laisse en liberté
complète toujours t'es pas obligé d de
t'ouvrir de vide et on sent toute ta vie
et de tout donner ce que tu as sur le
dos pour un jour aller dans un pseudo
paradis c'est pas ça le truc mais ça me
correspond mieux les jr se fit orientale
parce qu'elle nous laisse en liberté tue
en contact avec des gourous des sages
hindouiste rencontre actuellement mais
quand on me dit tu en as
oui on a un gourou et voilà que ces âmes
située saint bourrou écoles c'est un
vrai gourou cette une
c'est une communication avec dieu steve
mathieu c'est comme une douche tu vois
tu vas te mettre dessous c'est quelqu'un
qui a un qui n'a qui n'a plus d'ego et
quand tu le vois battue c'est que c'est
que c'est un vrai jean marie
et quelle est la plus grosse connerie
que tu fntv je crois que j'ai fait pipi
dans le bénitier de la petite chapelle
j'étais en pensionnat à l'âge de 14 ans
ça ça doit comme comme en réponse
pas du tout
[Musique]
quelle est la plus grosse connerie tu es
fait dans ta vie celle que tu regrettes
le plus
alors la plus grosse connerie que je
regrette je dire exactement ce que c'est
c'est 2 c'est de ne pas avoir
démarrer
mes conneries assez tôt si tu veux parce
que si je les avais démarré plus tôt oui
conneries j'aurais pu montrer ça à mes
parents et
malheureusement ils sont plus là je peux
pas leur montrer et pour moi ça c'est
une grosse connerie j'attends lui trente
ans avant de partir et aux parents
aurait été fier de moi associé
c'est ma plus grosse connerie ggp a été
précoce j'étais vraiment heureux
retardataires
le problème de cette le maïs et que tu
peux pas la racheter je sais pas c'est
ça c'est possible quand même peut-être
que peut-être que si ça marche après ce
que je crois si on a pas qu'une seule
ville je crois que ça doit marcher se
doit ça devait être vu quand même facile
à tu crois qu'ils te vois pardon je
crois qu'il doit réussir toutefois à
paris oui je crois qu'il me voit et puis
je crois que ton le fait si on le fait
pour quand même je crois que ça marche
quand même
tous croient donc il ya une vie ailleurs
tu pourras l'au delà absolument comment
pas croire qu' il ya une autre vie après
la vie en
on possède pas la vie en cela transmet
la preuve qu'elle ne meure pas est-ce
que tu est favorable au divorce
bah si elle maria à jouer sinon le
divorce
je sais des papiers de la paperasse
encore je suis pas favorable la
sexualité hors mariage on a sexualité il
faut bien répéter avant le mariage de
toute façon mais quand on est marié benz
a pu exister si certains ne trouvent pas
chez eux ce qui leur donne
ils vont chercher ailleurs
l'homosexualité c'est pas mon problème
c'était une solution
est-ce que tu est favorable la peine de
mort en ont il ya tellement de gens qui
sont pour que moi je ne peux être que
contre tout en précisant que je ne veux
pas non plus dans la catégorie des
sadiques qui préfère qu'un mec
pourrissent pendant 30 ans dans un
cachot quelconque bien que je peux me
mettre à la place de certaines personnes
dont récemment ils ont eu leur mot viol
et cetera jeu
effectivement je ne sais pas ce que l'on
peut penser à ce moment là quand tu
afficher un certain cynisme un certain
neil is me voir qu'est ce que tu as des
tabous tabou tabou et avoue tabou des
tabous non non pas vraiment y a rien
avec quoi tu ne rigolerai pas c'est à
dire que la seule manière de justement
ne pas en rire c'est d'en rire parce que
je crois tu crois en dieu je préférerais
que ce soit lui qui croit en moi me bats
et dieu c'est un vin vaste mot 1
il faut croire en quelque chose tu crois
que tu crois pas à ce vaste monde ah oui
faute groff un lieu où peut-être s'est
dit si nous je sais pas quoi faire venir
sur moi quelqu'un qui nous surveillent
tu penses que tu as un bon père
j'ai une bonne paire mais un bon père je
sais pas elles sont établies
jeudi je ne rigolerai jamais avec la
religion et le sida 1
c'est à dire que je n'ai jamais parce
que ça me fait pas rire mais c'est pas
des tabous je crois que j'ai aucun tabou
ya rien que j'ai cédé au comptoir bien
évité mais il ya des choses qui ne font
pas rire comme la le sida ça fait parler
parce que parce que ce n'est peut-être
pas et la religion n'ont pas comment je
crois en rire quoi je parle j'ai plutôt
qu'en train je suis vraiment une liste
quoi se dire que c'est un pas que je
crois qu'il n'existe pas c'est que je
crois que s'il est là je vois pas sa
place en tout cas je parle parce qu' à
quoi ils serviront jamais été effleurée
par l'idée de l'existence de dieu non ça
m'aide pas de savoir qu'il ya quelque
chose après que quelqu'un qui m'attend
après donc quelqu'un qu'il faut
recueillant j'ai besoin de savoir ça
c'est l'homme le plus fort
qu'est-ce que tu le regrette d'abord
c'est ça hein non parce que non parce
que du coup je suis mon propre dieu et
j'ai pas se donne une force ça me donne
un caractère de 20,4 chose quand on perd
et marque le pas été tentés de trac
rocher à l'idée de l'existence de dieu
non non je commence cette roche concept
risque maintenant il manque maintenant
sur le coup j'ai pas vraiment réaliser
quoi sur coup c'était c'était quelqu'un
j'étais triste pour l'homme mais elle
est comment dire la l'autorité garder
cet égard si le terme peut énormément
peur et et quand elle a plus été là
quelque part je mens
ça m'a aidé moi je me suis dit qu'il y
aurait plus jamais personne qui n'aurait
pas froid puisque malheureusement sept
personnes était plus là mais bon et
c'est maintenant par contre que je me
mets à pleurer dans un feu rouge parce
que je dis merde [ __ ] s'il était là
pour voir ce qu'il m'arrive serait fier
quand vous étiez petit
vous avez réellement voulu être
religieuse oui je devais avoir 5 ans
j'étais frappé par le rituel égalité
d'humeur
c'est à dire que dans la vie à la maison
c'était plutôt en dents de scie j'aimais
la musique j'aimais l'ordonance voilà
j'aime beaucoup la rigueur quand vous
dites j'ai un maître intérieur de qui
s'agit-il
jeudi à partir du moment où on n'est pas
perméable comme une éponge et où on ne
se laisse pas influencer par tout ce qui
nous entoure et qu'on ne vit pas que par
rapport au regard des autres au jugement
des autres
cette voie là s'expriment vous avez
toujours préféré le terme sensualité et
sexualité tout peut être un peu anti
sexualité en faut au moins dont on parle
et non parce que je laisse à mon rapport
décor une dimension
une dimension divine j'ai trop de
respect pour tout individu tout être
humain
à commencer par moi pour considérer que
le corps est un morceau de viande est
quelque chose qui dit se défait qui qui
pourrit et le rapport et la jouissance
le rapport d'essence et la jouissance
d'un une idée plus précise de l'extase
qu simplement un orgasme 1 coûte que
comme disait mon analyste qui laisse pas
grand chose de lui
nous sommes autre chose que de la
matière oui croyons dieu le terme croire
est un terme profane ça a à voir avec la
crédulité je ne crois pas ce que je vois
j'ai une sensation très exact de quelque
chose de deux magnifiques crayon là
l'esprit oui quand vous dites visseuse
et au mur seules la solitude n'est pas
une erreur épouvantable c'est c'est
quelque chose d'exaltant parce que la
solitude ne veut pas dire être isolé ne
veut pas dire être séparés des autres
c'est être avec les autres et si je suis
conscient de ma solitude je peux encore
mieux comprendre celle des autres et la
souffrance de ceux qui ne la supporte
pas bien view est ce que tu es
favorables à l'avortement
moi je me suis fait avorter plein de
fois j'ai eu un enfant je sais pas si je
me ferait avorter encore avec la même
facilité 10 en mai mais je trouve que
c'est un droit inaltérable la peine de
mort je suis contre je suis contre à 400
mille pour cent quand une société aura
prouvé qu'elle a le bien fondé de juger
on vous parlera des choses d'ailleurs ce
jour-là n'y aura plus de peine de mort
parce que rapide des lignes si grave
pour ça est ce que tu es pour la
légalisation des drogues douces
oui je suis pour la légalisation et
l'information de tout ce qui vous fait
du bien
quels sont tes tabou j'ai pas tabou
tu as dit une fois que tes héros
préférés étaient jésus-christ et
pénélope est ce que pour jésus-christ tu
peux nous expliquer mais c'est très
c'est très évident à comprendre c'était
un vrai révolutionnaire jésus-christ
jeudi en fait le vrai martyr c'est judas
parce que jésus la halle boral et judas
lui il est finalement jusqu'à la fin de
ses jours
il a le mauvais rôle c'est lui le vrai
martyr mais oui on peut très bien voir
ça comme ça ce qui prouve encore qu'il
n'y a pas d'ombré s'il n'y a pas de
lumière et qu'il n'y a pas de vie sans
la mort bien entendu que judas était
quand même la pierre d'achoppement de la
possibilité de sacrifice du christ qui
donc en étant martyrs reste un symbole
pour des générations et des générations
et des millénaires bien entendu que
judas est quelqu'un qui est un symbole
tout aussi puissant et que l'inde vers
rêver de l'autre retour d'un voyage aux
indes tu avais découvert le bouddhisme
et tu disais que le bouddhisme répondait
à toutes les questions qu'on se pose est
ce que tu crois toujours ça aujourd'hui
oui ça permet de répondre à toutes les
questions
maintenant encore faut-il pouvoir les
mettre en acte parce que ce qu'on pense
est une chose se compensent donc une
valeur sûre n'arrive pas l'appliquer à
sa vie mais il le dit d'ailleurs ça il
dit nous croire bien que tu une
expérience si tu avais un seul mot à
dire à sa fille un seul message un seul
conseil à lui donner ce serait quoi soit
toi existe résiste et en vie parce que
tant que tu as envie tu es en vie
est ce que tu crois en dieu
certains jours j'étais j'ai eu lieu vous
cru un moment j'ai eu une période de
suspicion temps dans ma vie mais
tellement naïve avec les images et les
séraphins et puis quand ces images là se
sont estompées de temps en temps sur
je me laisse aller à des des idées
d'infini c'est jeudi que pas trop
physicien et que ccc c'est tout sont pas
obligatoires mais qui n'a pas
obligatoirement en dieu qui m'entraîne
dans dans des univers taffin ans dans
lequel on rencontre des puissances non
identifié est ce que tu penses que tu
mérites l'absolution
je me la de notre étude favorable au
divorce légalement je trouve ça bien que
ce soit le divorce autorisé bien sûr
mais je trouve ça pas bien que les gens
divorcent mois à l'avortement
c'est dommage
c'est dommage qu'ils aient des
circonstances que les femmes soient
obligées d'avorter mais il faut bien
évidemment le continuer à faire en sorte
que les les lois qu'ils autorisent soit
respectée partout qui le tyran de
l'avortement libre gratuit si le des
criminalise que ces lois soient
maintenus ou créés à l'euthanasie
je suis fort et que chacun puisse faire
son testament et dire non mais c'est
vachement compliqué ça à partir de quand
est-ce qu'on peut décider qu'un mec
souffre trop et que s'il est inconscient
j'ai bon la question des routes et
priori je m'en fous à la peine de mort
bah non même pour les assassins
d'enfants
ça c'est la question vicieuse et obsède
par excellence même pour les assassins
d'enfants
c'est la question piège mais quoi qu'il
arrive une société civilisée peut pas
trancher la tête à un individu quoi
qu'il ait fait les tue favorable au
droit de vote pour les immigrés ouais
plus tôt
est ce que tu crois en dieu non mais je
fais gaffe quand même et je me conduis
je me comme disait brassens
je me conduis qui a plus mal que si
j'avais la foi si tu avais un dernier
message le brouillard se lève un dernier
message à donner à ta petite fille fait
quoi je verrai ça y est tu peux toucher
avec à la pêche
tu crois qu'on peut rire de tout ça
dépend qui écoutent rire de tout si tu
fais du mal à la personne qui écoute val
va te dire qu'on n'a pas le droit de
rire de touche on peut pas sortir une
blague antisémites à des gens qui
viennent faire un un pèlerinage au chili
c'est pas le moment
maintenant ces gens là ils ont l'humour
juif et si tu veux leur dire des choses
et ben attend qu'ils soient disponibles
mais quand tu dis par exemple que ton
grand-père la fête du cinéma qui est
joué dans le nuremberg à nuremberg qu'il
a finie mannequin chez mon savon est ce
que tu crois qu'on peut rire de ça dit
ça pour pas qu'on oublie un jour j'étais
par un pote son père et s'est occupé du
film shoah c'est lui qui a produit et je
lui dis alors ça te fait rire dit oui
parce qu'on en parle parce que les gens
n'oublieront pas est ce que tu es
religieux
j'ai des coutumes j'aime quand j'arrive
chez moi un soir de fête
voir mon père et ma mère heureux ma mère
elle a préparé le dîner
elle est heureuse mon père et les chefs
de famille et en bout de table
il a le sourire on est ensemble on perd
mais sa main sur ma tête
et puis je me sens protégée j'oublie mes
soucis parce que tu crois en dieu dieu
existe il existe quelques aujourd'hui on
peut pas dire autre chose que ce soit
lui qui ait créé les hommes ou les
hommes qui créé dieu de toute façon on
existe mais c'est pas grave je sais quoi
te confessé
30 - les années que ça n'est pas arrivé
je pense à téter alcoolique
ouais tu buvais combien d'argent quand
je me suis arrêté je lui apprenne un
avis de whisky par jour
je buvais pour me donner du courage pour
monter sur scène ont donné le courage
d'affronter les ennuis jusqu'au jour où
je me suis aperçu que c'est pour
l'alcool qui donne le courage de
remonter sur scène ni d'affronter les
ennuis avec un peu de volonté
ça va aussi depuis un moment c'est quoi
ya pas longtemps tellement de pression
des journal des mecs autour qu'il juge
sans arrêt quittant tué par terre te
laisse même pas le temps de te relever
parce que depuis qu'il m'est arrivé des
emmerdements et qu'on gagne ils n'ont
pas n'ont pas laissé souffler que
faiblement pour arrêter l'alcool net
tout ça non seulement je re langue là
j'arrête je me mets deux ans à la faute
et je me suis deux ans en afrique tu
craques jamais
ah non mais je peux pas si l'idée de
prendre une cuite me terrifie j'ai plus
du tout nous réveiller le matin avec la
tête présent comme je l'avais avant est
ce que tu crois qu'on peut rire de tout
non et quand tu dis par exemple en
parlant de ton fils qui est mort dans un
accident de moto il a trop bien limité
coliche ça c'est sur le coup parce que
le rire est une thérapeutique que je
conseille à tout le monde j'ai même dit
à main qui ont mal tourné est le mien a
pas tourné du tout
à propos de cette mort tu as dit depuis
je suis en survie oui personne leur
donnera mon gamin la plaie est ouverte à
vie je serai plus jamais pleinement
heureux je suis cassé dans ces moments
là t'as pas été tenté par l'idée de trac
rocher à dieu plutôt qu'à d'humour non
non parce que je me raccroche aux gens
tu crois pas en dieu tu pense toujours
qu'il ya rien avant et un après comme tu
le dis ça oui je pense qu à rien avant
et un après je pense je pense parce que
même aux moments les plus durs je les
pensais pas ce que c'était vraiment eu
l'occasion de penser qu'il y avait
quelque chose en disant aux secours
aidés - mais même là je n'ai pas pensé
tu pouvais changer le monde puis vrai
quoi si je devais changer le monde je me
changerait moi d'abord pourra totalement
apte à changer monde patrick quelle est
la plus grosse connerie que tu es fait
lanterner plus grosse connerie
e nouveau tôt j'aurais jamais dû acheter
et puis et puis peut-être une vie que
j'aurais peut-être pas dû choisir je
sais pas peut-être j'ai pas si c'est
vraiment une connerie parce que
finalement je suis quand même vachement
optimiste je transforme et les conneries
en rêve
finalement donc même si ça fait mal
je m'arrange pour nier que ce n'était
pas les conneries enfin par celle que
j'étais diao tantum ergo soit gravats
[Musique]
tenter comme halo
non je dis moi tu as dit les petits
anges
j'ai mis longtemps dans des bars assez
long faire le paradis aujourd'hui tu as
l'air un peu moins anticlérical
écoutez moi je suis un peu comme pascal
ce fait le même pari je ne parie sur le
fait que dieu existe
tu remarqueras au passage que c'est bien
un auvergnat de pascal parce que parier
sur dieye à cannes auvergnats qui évolue
pourquoi tu l'appelles le hasard dieu tu
trouves un autre nom toi c'est les
bisontins qui l'appellent le hasard mais
toile alors disons qu'à mais alors ça
tombe très bien parce que j'ai une
grande admiration pour la religion du
gentil c'est vrai que la bible est un
livre de chevet c'est exact tu lis
souvent tous les soirs et quelquefois le
matin et en plus c'est pas un bout
catrice très joyeux et assez paillard ça
dépend des chapais est ce que finalement
ça peut être illusoire de croire que tu
pouvait échapper au p'tit jacques du
collège
je suis toujours resté le p'tit jacques
du collège et les mêmes terreur je
déteste autant les adultes
je suis resté le garçon j'étais au
pensionnat il faut pas le dire ça me
fera du tort
un dernier mot à 10 mois
sophie duez bio julie devrais-je tulle
et choisit plutôt gironde tes
partenaires non
je sais pas j'ai tourné aussi avec
balasko lavanant je ne dis pas qu'elles
soient pas gironde mais tu as dit quand
le réalisateur aime l'actrice s'est
mieux style godard karina par exemple il
ya quelque chose en plus tu as dit alors
avec godrèche et quelque chose en plus
il ya quelque chose en moins avec
godrèche qui a le talent en plus de tous
et donc
qu'est-ce que de quoi un metteur en
scène pourrait-il rêver si ce n'est
d'avoir en face de lui une comédienne
qui a un talent extraordinaire et qui
est extraordinairement le personnage tu
refuses pas l'épithète de pervers que tu
préfères un malsain peut même dire que
tu l'as eu une sono pervers malsain est
totalement négatif disons que malsain
c'est un pervers raté mais
c'est bien la perversion c'est comme le
sait comme le piment dans la cuisine
asiatique c
dis moi me coûtait toujours aussi obsédé
par la mort ah oui oui bien sûr bien sûr
tu crois pas que si tu croyez en dieu
c'était vrai vivent certainement ça j'en
suis absolument certain mais on ne
décide pas de croire judith est ce que
tu pêches par orgueil
non
par avarice
est-ce que je pèche par un barrissement
par gourmandise
ouais
par envie par l'ubs sur non colère
paresse
non
est ce que tu crois en dieu
je dis mon dieu n'est pas le dieu des
églises c'est lequel non j m'arrive de
faire des prières
quand j'ai envie très forte que j'y
arrive d'ailleurs s'arrête jamais ses
courses je devrais peut-être croire en
dieu peut-être que ça aiderait pas ce
que je fais toujours des prières à mon
dieu donc qui induit indéfinissable
qu'est-ce qu'il est différent avec le
dieu dont parlait des gens qui croient
en dieu c'est un dieu un dieu à qui je
m'adresse quand j'arbitre humaine et qui
m'a déjà fait vous faites donc un petit
et j'avais dit que c'est peut-être pas
le bon là n'ont jamais mon neveu remet
pas en question locale c'est quoi leur
reviendront le suit une chose qui
n'existe plus ça s'est arrêté quand en
59 compresse le parti armé lui campe du
vinson avec résultat une petite part ça
il amour c'est quoi ça ça lui aura quand
même bon bah c'est fort je ne suis pas
d'amour je crois que beaucoup d'ennuis
et dieu dans tout ça
ben justement c'est dieu n'est pas là
alors que la pose et l'a mis la main là
où l'homme n'avait pas mis les pieds
donc très important de savoir après au
mur quand on est mieux
l'odeur de ton humour excellent est ce
que tu crois en dieu j'aimerais bien les
moyens mais croit-il en moins
j'ai eu l'habitude de se confesser quand
j'étais petit le mans non mais obligés
quand j'étais petit parce que j'étais
dans des institutions religieuses et
c'était une des obligations ça ne
plaisait pas du tout je pouvais pas
pourquoi il fallait que j'aille confié
un curé mes états d'âme je le fais plus
d'ailleurs c'est mon premier confesseur
depuis très longtemps cela vous antoine
wippert est ce que tu crois au péché
originel
non pas du tout je pense qu'on est on
est présumé innocent et que le reste
jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un ait prouvé
qu'il était coupable parce que tu fais
des péchés mortels en pensez seulement
on pensait
j'ai déjà de fait pas mal de monde même
une véritable hécatombe
il se souvient les péchés capitaux
est-ce que tu pêches par avarice par
exemple non non je crois pas que
l'orgueil oui bien sûr c'est pas du tout
empêché l'organisme croit que ont fait
rien intéressant sans orgueil les
gourmands des appareils gourmands disent
ces êtres vivants là quand été gourmand
cet homme lamy a pêché ça et l'envié est
un péché c'est à dire être envieux de
ses petits copains de ce qu'ils ont
mieux
ouais ça c'est pas une pensée c'est pas
une pensée très saine j'envie les gens
qui mériteraient général les gens qui
sacrifient leur vie
quelque chose de supérieur et différents
j'aime beaucoup les l'idée des gens qui
par exemple par deux dans les pays
sous-développés les médecins et qui qui
vraiment s'engage quoi qui engagent leur
existence c'est ça je te dire que ça me
rend c'est baba n'ont pas l'air oui
pierre fois par jour bien sûr pas toi tu
paresseux
benjamin heureusement j'ai pas j'ai pas
vraiment le temps mais si je me laissais
aller way que les tabous oui
l'inceste l'anthropophagie et des femmes
des amis est ce que tu crois en dieu
oui de tout mon coeur mais j'aimerais
bien que ce soit un tout petit peu plus
réciproque
vous dites est ce que tu as quelque
chose est reproché à n'ont rien du tout
elle et toi que tu faisais des films x
tu avais l'impression de commettre des
péchés utiliser un travail tu prenais ça
comme un jeu
en fait je crois que j'ai compris ce que
j'avais fait après sur le moment j'étais
j'étais très jeune et une sorte de
naïveté d'inconscience et
et je vivais je vivais les choses comme
comme aujourd'hui d'ailleurs quand tu
m'as pris conscience de ce que tu avais
fais ce que tu veux à regretter je me
suis empêchée de le regretter parce que
leur gré
peut amener la culpabilité et peut donc
nous écrire un peu donc nous casser des
autres donc je me suis empêchée de le
regretter
c'était à refaire mais je crois qu'il ya
certaines choses que je ne referai plus
mais changera pas tant de choses que ça
je crois qu'il ya je me suis un peu trop
un peu trop donner un peu trop gaspiller
et
je suis pas sûr aujourd'hui d'avoir
réussi à effacer tout ça il ya des
cicatrices qui sont quand même pas tout
à fait refermée et qui se referme ont
sans doute chan et quels sont tes tabu
ley tabou l'inceste évidemment parce que
parce que l'enfant l'enfant n'est pas en
droit de savoir ce qu'il a à ce qu'il a
ce qu'il a besoin ce qu'il a envie
le racisme je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses qui se font pas raciste mais qui
sont qui sont dramatiques
mais j'ai pas beaucoup de tabous non
parce que du gros en deux c'est vrai que
tu possèdes des actions charitables dans
les hôpitaux
tu le dit pas trop au centre parce que
ça c'est pas un c'est pas à crier sur
les toits c'est ma vie à moi et je le
fais comme ça sans tache
tu fais vraiment oui c'est vrai que la
marraine d'un petit garçon indien on
parle pas beaucoup w ban on n'a pas
forcément besoin de le crier son sont
les toits tout ce qu'on peut faire une
mais non si tu veux c'est une chose que
je fais parce que j'ai envie de le faire
et puis c'est tout j'avoue ne pas savoir
ne pas en prendre
non mais jour j elle reste un peu ce que
tu crois en dieu
oui tu prison
ouais tous les jours ça se traduit comme
quand tu pries une vraie prière ou si
une prière à toi qui est aussi ma vie
mes prières dans toutes les questions
ont été posées ce soir quelle est celle
qui t'a le plus embêté c'est que tu vas
me poser maintenant alors j'ai posé la
question comment ça se fait maintenant
répondre pour la dernière fois
comment ça se fait que tu n'es pas je ne
sois pas marié tu n'es pas d'enfant et
qui soit tout seul c'est comment c'est
possible sans quelque chose qui arrive
et je suis pas forcément tout seul c'est
tout seul que ça tue avec quelqu'un bon
bah non écrite
c'est ça qui m'embête c'est quand on
parle de ça et
je peux avoir ma vie à moi comment sans
forcément mentir ou vous très hachée
bien que vous disputez ces questions les
enfants les pousse pas je crois que tu
était sincère soit break tout compliquer
très cher tu crois en dieu
oui il arrive de prier déploie oui à ma
manière d'ailleurs ça peut être dans une
église mais ça peut être ça peut être
n'importe où mais ça peut être un moment
de la vie il faut que c'était arrivé
c'était quand le privé ça va pas
remonter si loin que ça j'ai déjà dit
prier je vais pas c'était quoi ça peut
être pour enrayer le fléau de certaines
personnes qui s'abattent sur certaines
personnes la maladie des gens comme ça
tu es un ami que les malades et de prier
pour lui j'ai une amie qui l'a
je voudrais qu'elle sorte deux sens de
ce qui est soi disant maladie cram
je pense que ça peut avoir un effet très
vite avec d'aussi de prier pour des amis
qui ne s'en sont pas sortis pour autant
mais ça n'empêche pas pressé est ce que
tu crois pas que aujourd'hui dans ta
carrière tu n'es pas encore complètement
débloqué veux pas te montrer tels que tu
es aux gens et finalement c'est un
blocage qui avait bloqué vraiment quitté
nuit sur le plan professionnel j'ai
essayé de comprendre sa de 500 jeux
j'ai une période de livres qui étaient
donc avant l'adolescence où l'âge était
spontanée après ça j'ai bloqué par
différentes de l'avatar de ma vie et
c'est vrai que j'en j'ai l'impression
d'en sortir un peu je pense que c'est
bénéfique évident patrick chez avec soi
même c'est un an à meilleure solution
quand on parle de ta vie privée par
exemple qui est lui toujours les
questions bourbon non parce que ça je la
vie privée impressionnant comme son nom
l'indiqué elle est personnelle jem veut
garder aussi j'ai pas envie que la rue
on me disent alors comment ça va à côté
du terrain
vous avez dit ceci ou cela est ce que je
peux faire quelque chose pour vous ça me
regarde que moi tu crois que tu
progresses aucun qu'un jour tu seras
complètement libérés ou que tu vas
rester bloqué comme non non j'espère me
libérer avant dans quelques jours à 10
ans parce que je crois que je vais vivre
vieux d'apprêter d'apprêter info ou
intox
c'est ce que souhaite pékin merci marie
inutile de te demander si tu est
favorable au divorce très beau concept
utile et je regrette que des boursiers
pas de repas aussi copieux que demain
que deux hawk au moment des noces
l'homosexualité je suis ensuite égalité
non pas moi un homme en face de tout ça
d'une banalité de fait normal absolument
normal tu as eu des expériences
homosexuelles quand même eu jamais
jamais dans le bouquin que j'écris j'ai
ralenti une folle était bourré ou jamais
trop d'eau explique nous avons fait mais
pour et je dis bien si vous le rendra
essayé tous les moyens pour et c'est
absolument moi personnellement je peux
beaucoup ça ne fait jamais recommencer
est ce que tu es pour la peine de mort
des fois il a faudrait la plupart du
temps non mais des fois il serait très
utile dans quelqu'un dans le cas de
gentils il faut vraiment du mal aux
autres et qui mérite sanction et qui
peuvent récidiver surtout qu'à des gains
de cette belle trace de gens qui il faut
les mâles et petits peuvent recommencer
caisson est à nous ou auquel je n'ai pas
tué près tout louis même l'inceste
ah bah non ce pavé turbo n'ont pas tout
tout ce thème est grand mot jeudi tous
ses atouts majuscule c'est une petite
foule est ce que tu crois aux quelque
chose qui nous dépasse et évident oui
par louis est ce que tu crois que dieu
t'a donné plus de donc à d'autres bah je
sais pas mais d'après ce que les gens
disent peut-être un peu plus les autres
est-ce que tu prends cinq antoine de
padoue will [ __ ] gygrid afin bye bye
et marc marié m'a fait retrouver est un
truc où il ya ça cache pas quelque chose
je m'adresse à lui et quand je retrouve
pas il a fait rarement et la showgirl
très sérieusement quand j'ai fait
réciter des patères des avait tout ça il
n'est pas fier est-ce que tu regrettes
pas un peu les fastes de l'église dans
le temps non je ne te mange des quatre
femmes et je trouve qu'elle a encore
beaucoup trop pense que le pack ad pa
bush qui va l'aimer yahiko said yabou
faire bol de riz ça surprend un peu
un ciné c'est la première fois que tu
entres dans un confessionnal
absolument c'est l'impact pourrait
tutoyer
les ouailles mais quel effet cette fait
bizarre mais ça manque de danse en deux
cierges et c'est pas très dansant non
c'est un peu le décor heureusement la
peine de mort ou aux comptes cours pour
la peine de mort
pourquoi à pour éliminer vraiment il ya
des ordures qu'ils n'arrivent pas de
vivre pour les criminels de guerre les
assassins enfants peut-être pas ça
dépend des circonstances atténuantes et
où enfin c'est pas contre la peine de
mort a priori gestuelle et m
par exemple les prolos légende en herbe
des immigrés ces gens là leur tapent pas
dessus le recouvre un tas de
circonstances atténuantes gérant je ne
me moque pas d'eux dans les dessins est
ce que tu crois en dieu
non jamais cru en dieu non c'est jamais
effleuré n'ont jamais un maire n'a fait
baptiser m'a baptisé je sais pas comment
ça s'appelle entre le puits terminé que
parfaite communion jamais entre les ans
sauf pourrez admirer qu'architecture non
je parle comme je ne sens pas concerné
dit si tu me crois qu'il est en enfer ou
paradis
je crois qu'il fait par les asticots
frais d'épicerie par charles ne pas
croire cette manche jamais su que je me
disant du pô le métier croit sort de la
merde facilement comme moi il faut que
je m'arrête vous donc c'est plus facile
de croire monsieur je crois beaucoup de
trucs mais pas dieu charlotte est ce que
tu prends un but oui depuis toujours
non depuis tous
et puis je prends que c'est arrivé quand
subitement qu'en quelques années
oh quelle occasion
je veux un peu du jour tout à coup j'ai
eu la certitude que c'était vrai et que
c'était même dieu pour tout le monde
je suis des listes jusqu'à série n'était
pas spécialement de catholiques non pour
moi c'est le même dieu pour tous tu
crois que tu ira au paradis ou en enfer
je crois que je vais revenir et coup sur
terre sais pas j'ai pas fini de revenir
j'ai par lg pas là j'ai pas eu le temps
de tout fâché d'avoir le temps de tout
faire
c'est quelque chose que je veux faire et
je vais encore venir un couche quand tu
as menée sur terre qu'ils effectueraient
envie de faire que tu n'es pas fait une
école
j'aimerais beaucoup créé une vraie école
et vous l'école dans les enfants rêvent
et l'école que j'ai détesté mois apprend
des choses à des enfants c'est ce qu'a
tenu parce que si tu fais des enfants
heureux et intelligent ça fera des
adultes heureux et intelligent donc
frédéric tu ne crois pas en dieu je
pense que dieu est
peut-être mais en tout cas certainement
sous aucune des formes que l'on nous a
enseigné et et moi j'ai samou finalement
ça nous c'est affreux à dire mais ça
m'intéresse pas
est ce que ton fils mathieu est baptisée
wii il est baptisé parce que
j'attache beaucoup d'importance ah au
fait qu'un enfant eux
soit comme les autres et ça fait partie
de notre culture de notre de notre vie
et après il est libre de faire ce qu'il
veut donc il ya des gens qui tiennent le
raisonnement inverse
moi j'ai préféré celui-là il accuse
maintenant il a 20 ans 21
on n'a jamais su si c'était ton ombre et
fils ou son office a devancé tout à fait
mon vrai fils c'était une c'est à dire
que c'est
il a vécu avec moi d'une manière un peu
compliqué à cause du désordre de la
jeunesse qui était ma jeunesse
en l'occurrence mais c'est mon vrai fils
et puis même si les témoins en fils
adoptif il serait aussi membre est fils
toute façon je trouve terrible cette
différence la seule chose qui compte
c'est la manière dont les gens
s'occupent des autres mais
en tout cas c'est mon vrai fils est ce
que tu vois toujours sa mère e
non parce que
[Musique]
la drogue a tué beaucoup de gens
qui l'a élevé je les ai élevés mais pas
très bien c'est à dire que je ne me suis
pas assez bien occupé que j'étais sans
doute un peu tyrannique avec lui je lui
a empêché de respirer quoi et
et voilà il faudrait lui demander à lui
si tu devais mourir là quelle serait la
seule chose que tu voudrais de vidéos à
ce moment là je t'aime et tu favorable
au divorce
[Musique]
non je pense que c'est une déchirure
quelque part qui n'est pas nécessaire
est favorable à l'avortement
je ne suis pas favorable à l'avortement
à l'homosexualité
je ne suis pas défavorable
je suis favorable à l'homosexualité à la
peine de mort alors là non c'est
impossible de vouloir là quoi qu'il ait
fait de vouloir la mort de quelqu'un
[Musique]
même pour les assassins d'enfants
oui parce que dieu est le seul juge dû à
la messe oui tous les dimanches non j'y
vais quand quand j'en ai envie
quand j'ai envie d'aller à la rencontre
des autres parce qu'elle est la messe
c'est aussi cela est-ce que tu
communiques ans tu vas la messe a
régulièrement mais eux au minimum une
fois par an se procure cohade communier
c'est quelque chose de très personnel
c'est une histoire c'est une affaire
entre dieu et moi j'aime bien m'entendre
avec dieu je m'entends très bien avec
lui tu lui parles bien sûr je lui
demande de t d non je lui demande
surtout souvent d'aider les autres je
n'ai jamais eu envie de fonder une
famille je ne rêve que de ça et je n'y
suis pas arrivé sacha distel et tu
favorable au divorce
non s'il ya des enfants
s'il n'y a pas d'enfant oui et tu
favorable à la peine de mort dans
certains cas
très précis oui particulièrement quand
il y as kidnapping d'enfants assassinats
d'enfants et quand cela est fait par des
gens d'une façon évidente recommencera
la légalisation des drogues douces ou
j'ai pas vraiment d'opinion oui pourquoi
pas dans les moments difficiles que tu
as eue dans ta vie est ce que non c'est
bon là est ce que tu t'es raccrocher à
l'idée de dieu est-ce que tu pris par le
nom je me suis raccroché à une idée de
quelque chose dans l'au delà
mais d'une façon tout à fait
inconsciente
j'ai plutôt une espèce de sens à ce mode
de la dérision et
ce développement fantastique du sens de
l'humour qui me fait un peu passées sur
n'importe quel autre notion dit moine
est ce que tu crois au péché originel à
temps puisqu'on à la rêverie de pêcher
est un péché qui doit être original
parce que je le fais tout le temps et
qui est que je ne vends que moi ton est
aujourd'hui toujours on me dit alors le
metteur en scène ça devient on toinon le
met en scène la pièce et daniel benoin
et saint-hyacinthe est produite à la
comédie de saint-etienne et alors il
faut le dire c'est le genre s'était
confessé dans le premier budget oui ah
oui cette annonce et il fallait
maintenant maintenant que je suis tous
deux viennent nettoyer toute ma vie de
péché non ce n'est pas le péché
d'orgueil c'est le péché du bo centrisme
rose à peu d'un péché dire s'il n'avait
pas eu le centriste uc voilà ouais parce
que tu pêches par avarice annonça
j'aimerais bien alors là à
est ce que j'aimerais bien après oui ce
que tu pêches par gourmandise
ah non pas gourmande non je fais la
cuisine comme ça fera mal je me démerde
non je suis pas très gourmand non parce
que tu peux je pars en vie wazemmes est
arrivé c'est pas toi je viens tu
l'invités concurrents crozet fait pas
tout les pauvres non ça m'est arrivé
venir ma soeur par exemple c'est une
love
le petit pêche par colère de rarement ça
faut vraiment non je suis pas tellement
en colère aux invités jusqu'à présent
les chercheurs bars fermés orgueilleux
la paresse la wii la galère sur pattes
après des monologues du new year parker
s'est pas de l'appareil le civ est ce
que ça j'apprends tout salut mais non
non je suis fait masser comme i am et
tout l'attirail une première tout tu
vois ce genre si je peux éviter mais je
sais pas moi de passer l'épongé sur
l'interprète de miettes j'éviterai tu
laisses le mien suffit à wittes ou
photos elles apparaissent plus quand je
pense que les interviews turquie dix
clés mais qui laisse deux minutes sur la
table c'est toi qui lui allait comme il
a calé et je n'empêche pas il n'interdit
pas qu'on passe l'épongé mais bon on
passe l'épongé ce que tu pêches par
luxueux et autres enfin le samedi est ce
que tu crois en dieu dieu directement
dieu non mais alors effectivement ces
tonneaux les progrès de la science
puisse qu'ils en arrivent à dire que
après le big bang lors la façon dont
l'univers s'est créé et organisé ne peut
pas contrairement à ce que praille et
mono ya quelques années être le fruit du
hasard
voilà il ya trop de coïncidences c'est à
dire c'est la science qui ramène à
l'aide des dieux au bout du moins de
quel s d'où vient cette organisation et
au diable tu y crois
les diables n'ont alors j ai jamais cru
même à l'époque je croyais en dieu grand
dieu mais est ce que tu crois au diable
oui parce que je crois que toujours la
dualité entre le jour et la nuit le bien
le mal et je crois qu'on peut
représenter aussi bien les forces du mal
que les forces du bien et que c'est pour
reconnaître les vrais valeurs il faut
faut en connaître c'est le mauvais
fruits
tu parle souvent du bien que tu fais ou
du bien et tu essaies de faire parts et
chaussons dans le message que tu veux
communiquer est ce qui t'arrive de faire
des choses du mal en tout cas
consciemment non mais
inconsciemment malheureusement oui mais
j'essaye de reconnaître mes fautes
lorsque je les fais lorsque je fais du
mal des fois c'est jamais
volontaire mais je peux pas dire que je
suis un sens à 100% et que je n'ai
jamais fait de mal
ça c'est ça serait vraiment dégueulasse
de ma part de parler comme ça qui est la
dernière chose mal que tu fais tu
la dernière chose que j'ai faite c'est
n'avoir pas suivi mon régime alors en
1970 avec ta femme vous décidé d'adopter
un enfant
oui vous demandez à terre des hommes
[Musique]
ça prend un petit peu de temps qu elle
est enceinte elle accouche et le
lendemain pratiquement vous accueillez
l'enfant que vous aviez demandé à un
tiers des hommes aurait dégénérée deux
pour le prix d'un
il s'agissait d'un enfant qui s'appelait
abdel qui pesait 10 kg et qu'il y avait
le monde ont soudé à la poitrine
oui qu'ils avaient creusé un énorme
montant avait creusé un trou dans sa
poitrine il était complètement roulé en
commun ni pour quand
c'était c'est quelque chose d'assez
saisissant avec des longs bras grêle
d'un thorax de poulet et enfin c'était
il était à prévoir et on l'a recueillie
et j'ai adapté j'ai donné mon nom non
sans grand chose ça a été la course aux
médecins ça a été pour le faire soigner
tunis mais abdel seule chose vraiment
importante que j'ai fait dans ma vie oui
je peux donner un sens à ma vie tu dis
oui j'ai été très à la période
d'installation d'abdel cap quand il a
été bien à la maison bien ans qu'on
l'avait bien pris en main tout ça je me
suis rendu compte que que la vie avait
vraiment insensé qu'il fallait aller
dans ce sens là il fallait continuer
j'ai failli j'ai pas me consacrer
créer une voie de ce genre pour les
enfants abandonnés
alors quand j'en parle et on me disait
c'est la goutte d'eau etc etc
à quoi je répondais que l'os est en
effet que deux boutons ou quoi c'est pas
et puis la lâcheté
l'égoïsme a repris 2 sur wii le dessus
et je vais pas donner suite à mon projet
qu'est ce qu'il fait aujourd'hui abdel
aujourd'hui il est retourné dans son
pays il est
il a travaillé longtemps à genève
ensuite il est allé au canada et plus
récemment il
il est parti en tournée en tunisie il
s'est marié d'ailleurs je dois dit est
une ravissante petite tunisienne mais un
amour de femme c'est y attendait chez
lui tu vois que tu gagnais un bout de
paradis avec endel
non on perd ça on va une passe du quart
a dit comme ça on y gagne bon c'est ton
comme on gagne le paradis jacky est ce
que tu t'es déjà confessé
oui j'entends un bruit bien sûr il ya
longtemps et plusieurs fois parce que
d'abord j'ai été élevé chez les heures
et j'ai fait ma communion privée ma
communion solennelle et puis enfin je me
dois dire que je suis sûr on n'arrêtait
pas de ce qu'on faisait j'étais à
l'église du matin au soir
et tu feras blut amusé ça c'est une
histoire terrible jeu de lire jusqu'à
maintenant j'aurais peut-être été
favorable mais je viens d'avoir un cas
dans dans mes relations d'une dame qui
était complètement complètement mais
c'était fini c'était un légume c'était
plus rien elle ne réagissait plus de
pour un peu on allait arrêter delà de la
soigner il va savoir ce qu'il s'est
passé d'un seul coup cette femme est
revenue à la vie elle est réelle
les partisans midi elle était alors la
latitude tu réfléchis quand même toutes
pièces que j'ai eu tort est ce que
j'aurai tort est ce que ça là tu
réfléchis vraiment après un coup pareil
tu fais vraiment la peine de mort
ah oui ah oui les hommes qui ont le les
femmes qui ont la la la
l'audace le la cruauté de martyriser des
enfants de les tuer les de martyriser
des vieillards de les de les tuer alors
là oui tout de suite tout une meilleure
je discuterai même pas il n'y aurait
même pas de procès arrière tout de suite
oui est ce que tu crois en dieu oui et
je suis obligé de parents dieu parce
qu'il est un gosse à 16 ans j'ai eu un
très grave at six ans je suis tombé de 7
étages par la fenêtre et je suis là s'il
n'y avait pas eu de mon dieu je crois
que tu me verrez certainement pas
croyable non non je pense pas mais je
pense que les gens qui sont très
méchants très enfin ça j'espère penser à
ça sont punis dans la vie oui mais un
juste retour des choses sales on retombe
sur le nez sais pas si c'est le diable
autre chose mais oui je veux croire à ça
si je devais partir là
et que ton fils michel à côté de toi et
tu es un seul mot à lui dit ah tu dirais
quoi si je vais mourir
ouais je dirais je t'aime je t'aime je
ça a été toute ma vie voilà je vous
dirai ça demis toi qui tu as prête à
faire une tournée des cathédrales tout
n'est pas surpris de te retrouver dans
un confessionnal
ah non pas du tout moi j'ai visite
souvent le monastère chinois en grèce
et j'ai des discussions longues avec les
moines sur beaucoup de choses de la vie
donc ça prouve que je suis un croyant
jeu pas très pratiquants d'ailleurs mais
les cathédrales les ou quelque chose de
mystique de magique et c'est un vieux
rêve que j'avais et c'est pour ça je
vais faire presque toute la france en
chantant des chants de noël des chants
religieux et puis quelques chansons de
mon répertoire qui s'apprête bien dans
cellule on a vu qu'à une expérience
mystique de 15 à 19 ans est ce que tu es
aussi attirés par le paranormal
tu as dit si je voulais je pourrais être
médium
pourquoi tu veux pas parce que les
touches des médiums ya pas certains gens
qui ne sont plus que les autres et
certains gens qui jugent qu'ils ont et
qu'ils souhaitent exercer plus que les
autres ce tour tu crois en la
réincarnation en 1976 tu disais être la
réincarnation d'alexandre le grand
ces derniers commencent battue c'est
nous les grecs on est tous un peu
alexandre des grenades tous types et
alexandre le grand est du genre bah
damour
comme chaque espagnol et le type est
donc qui cote en 1987 cette fois tu
étais convaincu être un ancien pharaons
qui choisit pas mal et j'ai vécu un
ancien l'egypte et je vécus au moyen âge
et je pense que je vécus avec alexandre
avec alexandre des grands macédonie et
mais je me cherche toujours
parfois tu dis aussi être un soldat dans
l'es7 d'angleterre et être moore d'un
coup de lance dans la gorge et tu dis
que pendant le temps où tu as été pris
en otage par les terreaux et si j'adore
ce ressenti une violente douleur dans la
gorge
oui ça c'est vrai ta grand mère c'est
vrai que tu la vois des fois derrière
toi et elle est toujours là et moi ma
grand mère et je la vois aussi tu l'as
vu ce soit ce soir non pas ici il ya
trop de lait trop de vibrations entre de
trop d'énergie trop de s'il y avait
quand même la peau spurs électrique ce
soir et c'est et je sais pas si c'est
dans toutes les émissions mais dans
celle là je suis sûr qu'ils en avaient
donc les banques espéraient bien pas
est-ce que tu est favorable au divorce
oui
ce qui serait une femme avec deux trois
ans quand j'ai quitté une femme avec un
enfant qui penche dès fois a toujours
oui mais j'y pense que la vie ne lui
empêche pas de les revoir et de devoir
élever ma fille bon je me suis marié
j'ai divorcé l'euthanasie tu serais
d'accord
dans l'absolu on dans l'absolu oui pour
avoir été confronté à deux trois cas
comme ça désespérer totalement oui
désespéré donc oui mais c'est un
problème très délicat de suicide
oui oui il n'ya pas commenter le suicide
je pensais être suicidé toi
non pas vraiment mais pour les autres ça
te fait pas peur il n'y a pas de pas de
peur à avoir pour les autres je pense
qu'on est
je pense que c'est aussi une certaine
façon une certaine façon à donner un
prix à sa vie que se suicider c'est une
espèce d'ultimes le pouvoir qu'on a de
vie et de mort de sa propre vie de sa
propre mort je vais ouais je vous en
prie est-ce que tu est favorable à la
peine de mort non pas du tout je suis
contre la peine de mort et surtout en
chêne pendant dix ans mais si ta fille
vous avez quelque chose à ton enfant et
tout ça je suis contre la peine de mort
même les assassins enfants même pour les
assassins d'enfants et une façon un peu
plus anecdotique je pense que je ne
pourrai jamais partagé une seule idée de
de le pen donc à partir du moment où il
est à ce point
pour la peine de mort même si j'étais
totalement ignorante de ce sujet même si
cela ne concerne pas je serai de
systématiquement opposés parce qu'ils
pensent le contraire et c'est très clair
tout ça s'y est dit favorable à la
légalisation des drogues douces
oui pour d'où ça veut dire quoi m
shittu ce contenu je sais pas s'il est
totalement d'accord pour enfin bon
oui je pense que ça changera pas trop le
problème il ya ya ya ya un certain
nombre d'exemples lalal hollande
l'espagne
quelques pays comme ça ça n'a pas trop
bouleversé le paysage politique j'allais
dire de ces pays
tu crois en dieu oui ce sera du moment
j'essaie de vivre ça au quotidien c'est
à dire que je ne suis pas pratiquant je
suis je suis juif au cas où tu ne le
serait encore pas donc je ne suis pas
pratiquant mais plutôt que d'attendre
des fêtes qui ou pardonne nous et ça
vous coq sgc au quotidien de de
comprendre d'être le mois banal et
médiocre possible et de donner un
maximum
c'est de la façon dont elles à moi d'y
croire tu crois au diable bah oui une
vérité une contre-vérité certainement
ja oui oui l'equilibre à ton avis quelle
forme il prend le diable aujourd'hui
tout tout ce qu'on est en train de faire
est diabolique
la conception de de cette émission est
diabolique
dis donc robert quand tu étais petit la
confession t'as pas mal donné non quand
même oui j'ai créé à samoa mais
peut-être j'y retournerais cette année
il paraît que depuis deux jours ces
défunts dans mon pool a dit mme harel au
lieu de mon père me plaît davantage et
donc c'est pour gagner ton paradis qui a
fait une chanson dédiée à jean paul 2
qui s'appelle pape nozick non mais c'est
parce que j'avais été bouleversée fier
par le fait que le pineau qui était puis
je ferai pas de l'humour qui étaient
rentrés par son embellie était vraiment
sorti par le trou de balle et jouer avec
ça méritait d'être
totalisé sinon c'est un personnage comme
on dit que je trouve relativement sympa
parce que même si inventorié y répète
des bonnes choses mais aussi tant
d'amour oui mais vous par contre hull 6
c'était moins fan tu raconte que ta mère
tu l'a mené à rome ou à voir le pape oui
et quand fait contrairement à ce qui
s'est passé avec beaucoup de gens quand
est arrivée la balle a perdu la fois
content et laurine commerce
quand elle a vu que pour seulement
l'élévation des choses et des photos du
pape au lieu de baisser la tête est là
elle a perdu la foi
ma mère avait laissés tels châtelet
toute sa vie et est pratiquante alalala
mais ce non seulement le dimanche mais
quelquefois la semaine sainte et policé
ses tout premiers matchs en tête très
mal shooté flatté je n'ai pas tellement
savoie et deuxio sais que ma mère qui
cherchait le bon dieu n'a vu que des
flashes de kodak et que des hommes en
nord est s'est évanoui et depuis que je
n'ai amené au vatican à rome et n'a
jamais pu remettre les pieds dans une
église catholique
je sais que je fais de la peine à des
gens qui croient à quelque chose mais
vous demander la vérité mon père vous
l'avez 3 calories mais j'en peu le ta
mère je crois que leur ai trouvé
sympathique mais c'est en même temps un
symbole d'une espèce de paralysie
mentale dans paris de l'univers sauf que
mieux vaut voir des gens suivent
idolâtrie quelqu'un comme jean paul 2 ou
que dès que des méchants que dès que son
équivalent en noir qui mettrait des
ondes négatives donc c'est quelqu'un je
discute pas pourtant toi tu t'es pas
mariés à l'église tu te maries dans une
chapelle kitchener mini chapelle blanche
à las vegas avec la
comment ça se passe je me suis mariée à
las vegas c'est un mariage valide parce
qu'on fait quand même à l'hôtel de ville
on donne notre état civil et tout çà et
là le le pasteur m'a demandé vous voulez
vous de la musique en boîte ou de la
vrai j'ai dit je veux pas de musique ça
me rappelle mon bureau on travaille tout
seul ensuite il nous a varié sature
exactement trois minutes et demie après
ça nous a donné quatre rouleaux de 25
sous pour aller jouer au lady luck
mais si on a une loi une pizza et puis
il ya place à du champagne l'état du
bébé doc soit c'était une des grandes
déceptions de mariage ma femme était
malade
est ce que tu es favorable sexualité
hors mariage au mariage ce que tu
trouves ton femme ou non parce que j'ai
un avantage d'avoir épousé une femme
bien vous dise qui est obsédé sexuel
comme moi loin pas de danger que ça avec
vous la peine de mort mais pour peine de
mort je trouve qu'on devrait choisir
mais quand quelqu'un la demande la peine
de mort devrait lui donner parce qu'à
être 25 ans d'aléas les borloo ou bien
tu mens ça doit être les prisonniers
devraient avoir le choix
est ce que tu fais avant de légalisation
des drogues douces et oui comme la
légalisation du porno ça disent des
choses que moins on a enfin comment dit
on a mis les qu'on n'a pas de but de ces
choses là mais plus et les galets et
moins on a en parlé moins on a envie
d'être d'en consommer parce que ce
qu'ils excitaient formidable des années
60 avec les drogues douces c'est que
c'est interdit c'est un petit goûter
l'évolution dans tout le monde en a
autant que tu te bats mais un grand
emprunt c'est tout ce qui est faible
abîme les poumons et donne un cancer du
poumon donc mieux vaut boire de la bière
blanche que de fumer quoi que ce soit
s'ils fument plus toi je fume
un peu de nicotine ou un bon joint de
temps en temps mais il soit très très
très très bon parce qu'il ya des clubs
là dedans c'est comme dans l'est
lorsqu'on demande si tu prends mon dieu
tu dis je sais pas je me demande si si
c'est pas une réminiscence de mots
l'éducation quand je dis mon dieu aidez
moi tu te demandes si c'est pas
finalement ton éducation qui t'a marqué
tu sais pas si tu confonds de bain je
suis un stoïcien shintoïste revisionner
s'attarder de gauche mais surtout que
l'unité est en ce sens que j'aime adoré
la nature les poissons
le soleil la lune soit je trouve que ça
c'est ça qui me enfin qui m'inspire qui
mêlait vers le haut qui m'inspire la
beauté mais mon idée de dieu c'est la
relation l'interrelation qu'il y entre
les ags de l'infiniment petit à
l'infiniment en iran mais cette espèce
de 2 ou alors je peux pas le définir
mieu x le l'interrelation interactions
ses sauts dieu pour moi il le dit appuie
croix non je voulais aller en enfer la
semaine dernière mais pas l'accès à
procès au feu on peut plier les
personnes tu veux toujours être enterré
dans ton pialoux banon j'ai déjà un pied
dans la bien fondée là pour déconner
qu'est la plus grosse connerie que fais
tu dans ta vie je sais pas j'ai pas mal
ma plus grosse
j'en sais rien quand il était marié est
ce que tu penses que tu a tout fait pour
garder ton mari ouais ouais si c'était à
refaire
qu'est-ce que tu ne le ferai pas
qu'est-ce que je referai pas depuis le
début de ma vie je crois que je serais
allé voir le en fait le premier garçon
dont j'étais vraiment amoureuse et que
je serais allé lui montrer mon amour
sans orgueil son me drapé dans un
orgueil et lapointe et je suis allé lui
dire que je l'aimais vraiment et je
l'aurai pas laisser partie voilà
pourquoi tout l'a pas fait parce qu'il
est mort maintenant que j'ai pas eu le
temps et j'ai été congelé pas face à
tanger attendu et puis bon il ya il ya
eu ça je crois que c'était lui et
l'homme de ta vie non je pense je pense
pas sinon resteraient pas moi ou alors
je serais morte aussi non j'ai enfin en
tous les cas j'espère pas parce que
c'est dans ce cas là ma vie est foutue
et puis si je pensais vraiment que ça
avait été l'homme de ma vie je pense pas
je vous serais mariée couple tu es
amoureuse en ce moment
content de voir en photo dans les
journaux avec un acteur américain très
charmant hôtel mais pourquoi parce que
parce que parce qu'on m'a trop volé ma
vie privée en la jetant en pâture au
public alors que j'étais pas d'accord je
suis d'accord de de donner un certain un
certain nombre de choses qui
m'appartiennent mais quand on vient de
les voler je suis pas d'accord donc
c'est pour ça que j'ai pas envie de
répondre à cette question
cette histoire là j'en vis de la
préserver et j'ai pas envie qu'on vienne
me l'a gâché avec des photos des cdd des
photos de paparazzi des choses comme ça
tu crois que tu vas être mariée mais
j'espère à 21 ans ça dommage de me dire
voilà ma fille c'est terminé pour toi tu
as plutôt en mariée oui j'espère que je
me remarier ils voient comment nos 20
ans non maintenant je me vois sereine
avec toute ma famille autour de moi dans
une dans une maison dans un dans un
endroit où je me sens bien avec avec des
rires tout partout je tenais une
baguette magique tu ferais quoi comme
métier j'avais une baguette magique
chanteuse de hard rock
ah bon tu t'es déjà confessé guy bah oui
comme tout comme tout bon chrétien à mon
jeune âge dans ton jeune âge pas
vraiment parce que tu as été baptisé à
17 ans quand ton frère s'est marié oui
mais j'étais croyant avant le baptême
n'est qu'une transition c'est un acte
écrit mais on savait rien
aujourd'hui tu es athée en fait ne rompt
pas vraiment je crois quand même il ya
des choses supérieur qui nous régissent
forces du bien et du mal
un jour je te vois un jour je te vois
pas et je crois que la véritable dieu
c'est notre conscience que tu crois pas
la résurrection par exemple tu crois pas
à la conception du saint-esprit non
c'est déjà du mal là j'ai du mal à
franchir sport c'est un peu trop facile
de croire que mais cela dit le message
laissé par le christ est une un message
de kim bien et quand même d'être suivi
approfondi respecté et on peut pas le
nier c'est un peu balinaise dix mois
maintenant tu au confessionnal avec moi
oui mon père quelle est la plus grosse
connerie j'ai fait dans ta vie le jour
où j'ai été m'installer le dans la
campagne giscard d'estaing
qui se passait du côté de la porte de la
villette dans les rôles dans le hall des
abattoirs et oui avait moi j'étais venu
comme ça ben c'est un petit mais pas
particulièrement d'idées par l'amour que
je pouvais porter à giscard d'estaing et
le hasard a fait que quand ils m'ont vu
arriver y moins immédiatement dirigé
vers l'estrade la plus importante celle
où il y avait les invités de marque et
où précisément à la place que l'équité
alain delon pour faire son discours mais
surtout il a bombardé par tout le monde
j'étais vieux trois jours après il a été
viré au moment où tu as été viré par à
partir des groupes tu as tu as vraiment
pensé à se suicider à ce moment là j'ai
pas été heureux non je peux être reçus
retour de la part de des groupes dont il
était certain que j'avais été un de ses
acolytes en 68 quand on voulait tous
refaire la france et quand j'ai
l'occasion de rencontrer
mitterrand quelques années plus tard
quand il mène deux ans plus tard après
selon pinsolle un an et demi plus tôt
même mitterrand m'a dit mais vous savez
mon chéri lui que vous êtes un
professionnel de la politique ne compte
pas dans notre pauvre dans votre
profession
par contre ceux qui courent devant les
roues et joaillier même nom de qui il
voulait parler et bien je l'aurais
jamais rien demandé et ils courent
devant les roues voilà ça c'était ma
consolation mais assez minime par
rapport à l'an et demi de plaka que
j'avais connu 10 - la connerie qui est
amenée en taule même si un an plus tard
pu été disons éclaircies de tout soupçon
tu as fait pas celle là bas se dire que
si je regrette de ne pas m'être rendu
deux autres fois de suite à la
convocation du juge d'instruction est
d'ailleurs le seul jour où j'ai quitté
le palais de justice j'ai dit à tous les
journalistes qui étaient là et
d'ailleurs je lance une petite pierre
dans le jardin des journalistes et de
tous les médias
c'est que pour ma sortie de taule comme
pour mon entrée j'ai eu droit aux
premières pages pour ma relaxe et mon
nom lieu j'ai eu droit à la quatorzième
page de trois lignes je te trouve
parfaitement incorrects et dégueulasse
de la part des journaux s'y joue tu
mourras ya ton fils que la roche ça
approche je te trouve encore très
enfants et on fisc et là tu es une chose
à lui dire tu dis quoi et a fait le
métier qui me plaît c'est de bien le
faire mais celui là si tu veux prendre
là le sillon que j'ai tracé ce serait
bien ce qui malheureusement pas le cas
pour l'instant
est-ce que tu regrettes ce que tu as
fait c'est soit franchement
kiri joie parce qu'on a fait je vais on
a bu un coup pas fumer un pétard quand
même pas trapy de gonzesses on a fait
des scores comme un peu quoi je pense
que tu regrettes pas fier pour être
aussi méchant parce que tu sais bien moi
j'ai une ambition quinquin but eut qu'un
désir dans la vie c'est de te ressembler
parmi toutes les personnes que tu as
cassé dans les médias est-ce qu'ils
aient la paix aujourd'hui à qui tu as
envie de demander pardon et laquelle je
casse pas pour le plaisir de casser je
dis ce que je pense et des fois ce que
je pense c'est cassant mais c'est pas
pour faire de la peine je dis ce que je
pense des gens voilà et dans un métier
où je ne fais pas vraiment ça peut
surprendre mais pourquoi tu as côté un
peu fouillis mais franchement entre nous
c'est pas fou il maire de o sens presse
à scandale vraiment c'est que ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la nature humaine et
les faiblesses des gens connus c'est une
façon finalement de démystifier
peut-être un peu les gens connus parce
que là les gens connus c'est avant tout
on est connu c'est des gens ça passe par
ces questions là ce que tu veux
démontrer ça passe par des questions
intimes parce qu'effectivement c'est
dans l'intimité que tout le monde et le
plus semblable
tu dis souvent fin du mois dit souvent
qu'il faut pas trop déconner avec la
religion parce que toi qui rit tu as
peur de tout brûler en enfer
franchement thierry tu serais pas un peu
con c'est vrai que c'est un peu con de
dire il ya deux choses que je respecte
c'est le roi et le pas bon ça semble un
peu bizarre on dit ça pour donner un
c'est du marketing en fait je crois pas
vraiment je crois que moi j'aimerais
mieux qu'ils aient un roi en france
c'est vrai c'est sincère là aussi ça ne
fait pas que des amis ce truc là parce
que pour les français après 200 ans de
propagande républicaine il confronte un
peu louis saez adolf hitler quand même
quelque part donc ça ne fait pas que du
bien ce truc là
le pape c'est pareil pour moi la
personne que je préfère au monde c'est
le pape
surtout celui là alors j'aime pas qu'on
rigole avec la religion d'abord parce
qu'on tire pas sur les ambulances je
trouve que c'est un peu facile de faire
l'anticléricalisme il ya 90 ans qu'on en
fait je suis sans doute un peu con oui
de croire que que si je suis pas gentil
sur la terre que si je fais du mal je
vais landes en faire brûler dans des
flammes ça c'est un peu con mais on peut
appeler ça le karma j'ai pas envie
d'avoir un mauvais karma voilà ça c'est
déjà un peu moins con le dire comme ça
non si ton père débarqué là sur le
plateau comme dans secret soirée où la
conscience d'arthur tout à l'heure tu
lui dirais quoi bein je dirais que c'est
un peu grâce à lui que je suis là parce
que je crois qu'il voulait être
journaliste et puis là pas pu et que en
tous les cas il m'a toujours donné le
goût de la presse de l'info de la vérité
je crois que toutes les vérités sont
bonnes à dire c'est quelque chose qui
lui qui comprend
je crois que je dirais ben voila tu vois
ça c'est pas seulement parce que tu es
mon père que je suis là c'est aussi
parce qu'en 54 tu m'as fait goûter
europe 1 matin alors je dirais merci pas
seulement d'être mon père quelle trace
tu vas laisser la pâte à disparition
j'aimerais rester comme un empêcheur de
tourner en rond mais pas uniquement
parce que je redis aucune la télé mais
qu'est ce que tu aimerais que tes gosses
10 de toi c'est fini je sais pas ce que
j'aimerais qu'elle dise que j'ai été un
bon père mais j'ai pas le sentiment que
je suis tout le temps tellement je bosse
quoi donc j'aimerais qu'elle me pardonne
et qu'elles disent d'accord on n'a pas
beaucoup vu mais il a fait des émissions
de télé qui était pas trop mal il a fait
des bouquins qui était pas trop mal il a
fait des journaux n'était pas trop mal
voilà quelle excuse mon absence par deux
trois conneries que j'aurais laissé moi
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu